LIKE ASS.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I KIND OF LIKE IT.
>> YEAH?
YOU LIKE TRASH SO MUCH WHY DON'T
YOU LIVE IN IT?
>> WHY DON'T YOU BITE ME?
>> DAMN, OSCAR, WHY YOU SUCH A
GROUCH, MAN?
>> FROM THE STUDIO THAT BROUGHT
YOU "JOKER" AND THE TWISTED MIND
AT SESAME WORKSHOP COMES THE
NEXT GRITTY ANTIHERO, "ORIGIN
STORY."
>> WHY DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
ALWAYS IN SUCH A BAD MOOD?
>> THAT AIN'T ME.
THINGS ARE GETTING WORSE OUT
THERE.
>> ONCE FRIENDLY NEIGHBORHOOD OF
"SESAME STREET" HAS NOW BECOME A
HAVEN OF CRIME AND CORRUPTION.
I'M GUY SMILEY, ABCDEFG NEWS.
>> HOOKERS AND PIMPS ON EVERY
CORNER.
>> NOW, LOOK, PRAIRIE DOG, YOU
WANT TO SNUFF HIS HO'S.
OKAY?
AND SNUFFY'S HO'S EARN.
>> I'M SORRY, DADDY.
>> BITCH, YOU BETTER SHUT THE
[ BLEEP ] UP.
>> PEOPLE ARE GETTING KILLED
OVER NOTHING.
>> GIVE ME THE DUCKY.
>> ERNIE!
GIVE IT TO HIM!
>> TELL HIM, NO, BITCH!
>> NO!
>> AH!
>> HOW DOES THAT MAKE YOU FEEL?
>> GROUCHY.
♪♪♪
>> WHEN EVERYONE CALLS YOU
TRASH, AND EVERYONE TREATS YOU
LIKE TRASH, WHY DON'T YOU JUST
BECOME TRASH?
>> AND OSCAR THE GROUCH, SAYS
THE "NEW YORK TIMES."
LIKE YOU'VE NEVER SEEN THEM
BEFORE.
>> DO YOU WANT TO SEE THIS BIG
BIRD SING?
>> OOH.
>> PLEASE.
PLEASE HIM FOR ME!
♪♪♪
>> I'M INNOCENT.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO SELL NO
CRACK.
YOU ONLY ARREST ELMO BECAUSE
ELMO MEXICAN!
♪ SUNNY DAY ♪
>> FROM DIRECTOR, TODD PHILLIPS.
♪ SWEEPING THE
CLOUDS AWAY ♪
>> AND THE WRITER OF "P IS FOR
POTTY."
♪ ON MY WAY TO WHERE
THE AIR IS SWEET ♪
♪ CAN YOU TELL
ME HOW TO GET ♪
>> WOULD YOU DO ME ONE FAVOR?
COULD YOU CALL ME THE GROUCH?
>> BROUGHT TO YOU BY THE
LETTER R.
>> SCRAM!